the last Ukrainian troops remaining in
the besieged port of mariopol have
defied a Russian deadline to surrender
more than ten thousand civilians have
been killed in the weeks-long
bombardment Moscow estimates around two
and a half thousand Ukrainian soldiers
are holding out at a huge steel plant
Russia's defense Ministry says it will
destroy those who continue to resist
Ukraine's prime minister says the city
has not fallen and its forces will fight
to the end
well for more on the military situation
in Ukraine we're joined Now by former
military intelligence officer Frank
ledwich who's in Oxford in England hi
and welcome to DW now the Ukrainian
forces in mariupo have rejected an
ultimatum set by Russia with the
Ukrainian prime minister saying they'll
quote fight to the end in mariopo but
what can the Ukraine can the Ukrainian
forces actually hold back the Russians
well they can hold back they can hold
them back as long now as they survive
what they've been given it seems to me
is a No Quarter order by their enemy
which is to say that there is little
point in you surrendering because we're
going to kill you anyway which is
entirely contrary to the laws of war the
laws and customs of war and of course
the Geneva conventions
one of the problems of giving a No
Quarter order is that you encourage your
enemy to fight to the death and it seems
to me that that's
the direction this is going
yeah well how strategically important
then is mariupole for the Russians
okay it's important for two major
reasons the first that it would open the
way for a land Corridor between the
occupied Don bass area and the equally
occupied Crimea now currently the only
conduit between Russia and Crimea is
effectively a long bridge that they
finished I think about three or four
years ago in Kirch Straits now they'll
have a land Corridor into the Crimea so
that's the first thing second thing from
the perspective of the direct military
situation there are between six and
eight Russian Battalion combat groups
which are about about in theory a
thousand men each but of course probably
significantly less now they'll be very
ravaged but those would be released and
the units supporting them probably to
strike North into Ukraine which will
will be a problem for Ukrainian forces
and that's one of the reasons these guys
have been given the orders to fight on I
suspect
let's talk actually a little bit more
about uh Russia's strategy now they've
confirmed the death of General Vladimir
frolov another high-ranking uh General
who's killed in Ukraine
um what does this tell us though about
Russia's military strategy
well the first thing it tells us is that
they're not very good at command and
control one of the advantages that
Western forces has demonstrated over the
last 30 years is they give a great deal
of initiative to the forward commanders
these generals who have been killed
which by the way constitutes about 30
percent of their General General
officers so far that that's an amazing
number if we just take into account that
in the 15 years or so in Vietnam the
Americans lost six Generals in 51 days
the Russians have lost eight full
generals but what's happening here are
two things first the generals are going
forward to sort out mess created by the
fact that there's very little initiative
to be had in their lower lower officer
orders as it were and the second thing
is is outstanding targeting by Ukrainian
forces which I suspect is being assisted
by by Western and NATO NATO intelligence
one thing NATO has been very very good
at in Afghanistan other places since
high value targeting and these channels
are high value targets
Frank Russia has also lost its Black Sea
Flagship muscover this week but it also
leads me on to wonder how long can they
continue to suffer losses like the ones
that we've seen so far
credible estimates of the losses the
Russians have taken are between 25 and
30 percent of their initial Force
problems the Russians have is that they
don't have the kind of Reserve System
that say the Americans have or the or
most Western countries have nor do they
have the depths of Manpower that say the
People's Republic of China have so what
they're trying to do now is essentially
scraping the bottom of the barrel for
for soldiers they have called up their
very few reserves those who have been
serving or stopped serving since since
2012 and they'll take a long time to get
them into the front line they're also
suffering endemic problems of corruption
within their ranks which which also
thins things out in terms of Manpower
inefficiency they're in very serious
trouble in my estimation and that isn't
necessarily entirely good news because
it raises the possibility of escalation
using weapons other than standard
conventional Battalion combat groups
military expert Frank ledwich in Oxford
and England thank you for joining us on
DW
thank you Pablo
well DW correspondent Rebecca Ritter's
is in Kiev for us hi Rebecca good to see
you now the deadline has passed what is
the latest we know from mariupo
that's right Pablo the Russians gave the
Ukrainian soldiers until 1300 today
local time to come out with their hands
up or risk being shot being killed they
have seems it would appear have ignored
that order as as you're reporting the
Prime Minister saying that fighting
continues it isn't all that surprising
the as of Battalion those Ukrainian
soldiers defending the city have said
that they are going to fight till the
end they've said that all the way along
since the beginning of this war and
they're famous here in Ukraine for for
managing to defend that City back in
2014 when Russia invaded the first time
so it's very unsurprising that they
haven't heeded that warning now mariu
poll has been under siege four weeks as
we've been reporting and they're just
true atrocities and Devastation coming
out of that City the stories are truly
shocking but it is a key Target for
Russia both tactically and territorially
if they are successful in taking Mario
poll it will link up areas that under
their controlling Crimea and the Don
bass and also really give a big knock to
the Ukrainian economy uh not able to use
that port to export its steel and weight
and other products so definitely a key
City both sides are fighting till the
end ukrainians definitely outnumbered
but it isn't over yet
now president zelanski warned Russia
peace talks will end if its forces kill
the Ukrainian troops defending mariupal
has there been any reaction to that
well that's right I mean after that
directive or the that ultimatum was
given by Russia zielinski came out and
said that you know if the if the
Ukrainian soldiers are killed then any
peace negotiations or peace deal would
die with them uh but in reality those
peace talks have actually been uh on
hold for some weeks now ever since
Russian soldiers retreated from areas
around Kiev around here where I am uh
the atrocities that that were found in
the wake of their Retreat the retrieval
really put the talks on on a back burner
anyway the ukrainians and Russians not
speaking to each other for several weeks
for a couple of weeks now sorry uh we we
were hearing rumors that Russian
oligarch Roman Abramovich was in town
he's of course famous for being the
former owner of Chelsea Football Club he
was apparently here trying to sort of
revive those talks but today the foreign
minister has said that Russia and
Ukraine are not talking so definitely uh
still on Ice whatever happens in Mario
poll will be decisive and whether or not
those talks can continue
Rebecca Ritter is in Kiev many thanks